>> Like not having
to work on Labor Day?
Or not having to go
to school on Labor Day?
Why you reading, bitch?
Of course!
Unless you're a freak.
But while you're watching
this...
Change the channel.
...and avoiding small talk
at your neighbor's barbecue...
Now that's a hot dog!
...or at your co-worker's
awful party...
It's really great to be here.
There’s nothing like a party.
...raise your light beer...
Mmm-mmm, bitch!
...to the group
who made this day possible.
Hooray!
Unions!
FYI: Labor
Day started as a day of protest
>> and now it celebrates
the labor unions
that fight for workers’ rights.
Without these rights, all of
our jobs would suck way more.
Abbi, could you clean up
all the sweat?
It's actually my lunch break.
Good call. It'll totally be here
when you get back.
Imagine your life
without the eight-hour workday.
How long have we been here?
Could be years. Paid time off.
You guys could stand
a little vacation yourselves.
Look how tired Tim looks.
That's just the shape
of my face, sir.
Workplace safety regulations.
I just realized I'm supposed
to meet a friend for lunch.
Child labor laws.
And my knees are intact,
so I make
a perfect ottoman.
Sick leave.
Ohhh...
And the freakin’ weekend!
Yay!
Basically I'm trying to cram
my entire life into 48 hours
and I won’t enjoy
a second of it.
The fight was never easy.
You're going to jail.
And it certainly isn't over.
Viva la revolucion!
But it’s everyone's fight.
So don't be a dick. He did it!
Did he? Yes, he did!
And use today to say:
“Thank you, unions!”
Really. Definitely. Totally.